all right so what are your names uh for
me my name is my name so tell me about
your lives you grew up where your
friends from way back right yes we grew
up on the Eastern country is called that
but from not even part of Thailand is
normally how far from Bangkok
um
yes it take a bus about 10 hours yes
yes so out in the
countryside yeah and tell me about your
families
no family now we are uh my parents about
the farmer they're working a farm and
have some sugarcane and yeah they work
at home
my family my dad
my my mom him on own already then I have
my family I have two young brother now
him still study and spend money from my
family so the money you make at the club
yes in the bar you send back to your
family yes and same thing with you yes
is that pretty much what all the women
all the all the ladyboys are doing is
sending money that they make at the club
back to their families yes normally
Thailand like that we we take care of
the balance when yes when we go up and
then the children take care of them yes
and tell me about your childhoods good
childhood or was it rough
when you were young when you were a
young boy how was it oh wow in my family
for me well they are really open for me
yeah they accept they know what am I in
when I was young that's great yeah they
I'm not probably even though we are we
want to be right though we long hair
want to have big move once you have
oh my body look like lady yes I think uh
the the family really often except yeah
really I think that that's something
that goes on in Thailand it doesn't
really happen in other parts of the
world
yeah a lot of transgender people have a
difficult time with their family yes but
but for us maybe a little bit lucky for
the family who accept and open for for
me for for us yeah
are you closer to your mom or your dad
um yeah I'm really close with Mom yes of
course that's why we try and we want to
be like a mom we want to be strong like
her yeah same with your milk yes yes
same because I'm the first of my family
and the first in you know I have Yamato
right I'm the first
and must are working a lot a lot spin of
my family and support them support like
a brother because my dad my mom him on
already him cannot working then I am
Machu working hard
how old are you guys
um this year we are 30
yeah same same age you went to
University together yes yes
University but separate uh correlate
mean
but you ended up doing this kind of work
I tried to work hotels I try to working
in the hotel but it's not
not good money for me it's not enough
money for me you could get a job but it
wasn't enough money
yes because um it wasn't a problem
because you were transgender yeah
transgender need more
because we need to be
to surgery we need to you know make
something beautiful for myself and yeah
this kind of beauty does it doesn't come
cheap I guess yes normal work work hard
but not much money for no no not not
enough for me yes not enough for us
because yeah
[Applause]
my dress my
when did you start making the transition
to being a woman wow
um I think many years ago like 10 years
ago that's why we try to you know like
uh want to be a long hair like
take some more hormone to be like smooth
skin for for more beautiful yes Mr I
think more than 10 years ago yeah yeah
you guys are taking hormones yeah still
still and you've had some surgeries yes
of course and the hormones seem to make
like your waists are very small to
people typically men don't have yeah
like you guys do come on lady
body also hair also skin tonsil I think
yeah that's it your voice too maybe
yeah yes
sometimes little boy right why is flight
the boy but we are
but boys can make it you know sometimes
you can pronounce like a
bakes and also can control like a small
like I think but but my voice is
original not operation yeah yeah she
also
and you're happier this way you guys
seem happy yes I think um we also
be I think
people around me family and work and
friends I think just make me happy
that's nothing to to serious because now
we we can take care of family and
you know take care of ourselves and my
family
it's great I'm happier because yeah
looking to support of them yeah tell me
about working at the club
so you work at a club called Obsession
yes in the Nana Plaza it's like a
shopping mall
and and a man will come in yeah yes and
he'll see all you guys up on stage
dancing and he'll pick out one to talk
to and yeah you guys negotiate and
you'll go off to his room or you guys
have your own room yeah yeah either way
and
and you you'll have sex and then then
God we can't depend on that we uh decide
to go with him or not also yes sometimes
because
um we cannot say all the time go go go
because it need to be like a totally
like time yeah talking about how about
him what we are do with them yeah
sometimes I got customer with a
girlfriend and boyfriend right and
treason
do you think it's more accepted in
Thailand to be transgender yes I think
it's really accept in Thailand but uh
not so illegal yet but yeah people can
say yes can you guys get married
you
could not marry a man
yeah
I cannot marry
men and men can marry
mm-hmm
but if you're just out and about you're
going out to dinner you're at a grocery
store or whatever
you don't get picked on you don't get
any terrible
no reactions from strangers because
you're a transgender
in some cases it's very difficult
but that stuff does happen sometimes
yeah so of course it's happened like in
the United States it happens a lot I
think yeah I can see I can see
happen sometime
and so you guys have some male equipment
yes
still
have and you're fine that way that's how
you want it
is that right yeah or would you rather
be have that removed and yes now we just
keep it we just enjoy that and I think
not happen right now operations
in the future who knows right yeah
that's like a new hybrid sex yeah
something like like that because there's
some men like something different some
man right like a lady have penis yes
yeah I think a lot of a lot of men like
that yes yeah
maybe exciting for them yeah they said
it because wow you look like lady but
you have holidays yes
if wow it's a pie
yeah it's a whole new world yes on the
world how about you
how about me you know I I like I like
regular girls are you ready yeah but I
will admit there are some beautiful
women a man say also like you but you
know sometimes they try and then they
change their mind yeah
I could see that happening yeah yeah you
have you have next you know you have
somebody in your bed you find out has
some other sometimes they don't need
like uh oh sometimes they
don't care like a lady or [__] but
sometimes they just click together
sometimes they just talk or they just
good together or you know like just
feeling good together not not like a sex
not just lady or [__] or because now
we are like equality like everyone the
same we're also people yeah and if two
people click two people click and that's
it yeah that's it
it's not about whose sex is what yeah
now the world really changed and you
know going to the world is changing yeah
next level like
a lot yeah things yeah things are
changing quickly yeah or drugs or
alcohol a problem for you guys
for me not much no no I'm not drinking
much
and no drugs no drop yeah it seems like
there's I don't see anything I think
it's good for our lady to who don't have
drug or alcohol Mass because can can
keep the body like still beautiful and
you guys all look healthy
yeah the whole club it's like you look
at all these
yes because they sell the drinks but
they're not making a lot Brown can
cannot work in yeah yeah not to control
to until through o'clock until back
close
hey how many nights a week do you work
oh wow um
good question
normally like a
four or five day per week four or five
yeah because they need the lady to take
that they off like a
what do you do with your free time it's
free time you'll do what
in the free time yes free time it's not
working what do you do
you live in Bangkok yes we like to eat
we like to shopping sure yeah because
I'm reliable yeah whatever girls do yeah
they like sometimes don't need to talk
with anyone sometimes need to because we
are working it so I try it but to
their own yeah also can go the temple
sometimes
so you're religious as well yeah
what do you worry about
everyone worries about something what do
you guys worry about
um I just really about how when when I
get on what the how yeah some something
like that
like all women do they worry about
getting old yeah getting old and then
how we
live a life how who will take care of us
who you know yeah some something would
you like to fall in love with a man you
guys deserve love just like anyone yeah
you stay in contact with your families
you know they understand that you're
working at this club yes your family's
no yes no because uh if him don't know
him how
I can
make money a lot spin off them
not a lot for the month for one month
Allah is not a lot yeah is this a busy
season right now or a slow season
yeah but the browser is hacked with
people yeah they're always busy in Nana
Plaza but some sometimes you know like
you can see busy outside but sometimes
in size not much yes yeah because uh
also like a medical working inside right
as you see so many competitions like uh
they're not a plaza it's something else
I mean it's a three-story shopping mall
yeah you can see like a many products
the man can buy how many clubs in a
countless clubs oh wow every floor is
maybe seven eight nine clubs on it each
Club has 30 girls 50 girls working yeah
60 20 if Friday Saturday is a lot much
more than another day because we have
all these clubs offering sex yeah you
have a sea of men climbing all over the
place yes it's crazy they come from all
over they come from United States they
come from Australia they come from
Europe
yes
Europe European guy
not Asian guy
really yes what are your favorite what
are the easiest what are the nicest
customers
[__] is so cute
and how do the Europeans treat you
I imagine the Europeans are probably
know how to treat a woman they
spend money yes
to treat you with respect they like
something different they're like you
know European they're like funny go
they're lighter friendly they're like
yeah I think my friends is really
yes exactly for them like because people
who come here they don't want something
serious they like to something say
something beautiful some things so with
my something like yeah welcome to drink
you know because sometimes a man may be
serious or something else from work from
family who yeah we don't know but we
just
make them happy when they go back all
right yeah I think for a lot of men that
are probably tourists visiting Bangkok
what you guys offer is something that
isn't available anywhere else in the
world for them yeah I think it's really
like a species that doesn't exist in
their hometown
yes sometimes we also yeah I think lucky
for us to work this because you can see
can also practice my English can see
people can
yeah it's good that so so you guys are
happy you you seem happy yeah we're
happy right now we are happy right now
we're happy it's a good way of saying it
yes
and what would you guys say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
for me
um I think
make me stronger like uh make me growed
up like uh
and also my thinking gonna be stronger
like I put always positive things and
discussing that
if you think good and then the good
things also coming it's wonderful yeah
yes
same for you same same yes I also taste
tell her like yeah me to be positive and
even we are you know in that situations
need to be
yes protein and then you will be passive
because he's working long time more than
me then she can tell me how to do
um for
I think four five six seven years
something yeah that's only five five
years you've been doing it how long
five months five months yes but but we
work another but not mean this by in
seven years because because uh before
Kobe that's why we moved to there yes
yeah because it's covered everything
closed down yeah everything is shut down
there so things are back in business now
I got hope getting better and you know
people not just me and also my friend
who worked there they they will have a
life you know they will have like uh
support family because some girl it's a
hard situation in the cold time so they
lose the job they lose the money they
yeah if everything's sad like now I just
hope myself and my friend there getting
better and yeah thank you for you to
Camping yeah
see asked about talk about something
like that yeah yes you guys have
interesting stories ah
can tell like a guy until
you're amazing thank you so much thank
you thank you thank you